good morning it's seven o'clock this is
sky news breakfast
after the government suddenly changed
the quarantine rules for thousands of
british tourists on holiday in portugal
it's been a night of rearranging flights
home
airlines expecting to fly thousands more
to the algarve this weekend
say the decision is disappointing and
confusing
we'll be speaking to the housing and
community secretary robert generic
in a few minutes as well as one of
britain's biggest independent
travel agents also this morning
[Music]
[Music]
we'll talk about the first authorized
film to portray the life
and achievements of the legendary soul
singer aretha franklin with the pop star
sunita and before the lockdown the
british
film after love was winning awards
around the world
director and writer alan khan joins us
as it finally hits
uk cinemas it's friday the 4th
of june seeing red over amber
fears of another lost summer for the
travel industry
as british holidaymakers rush to fly
home from portugal
as quarantine rules change these
decisions are very politically driven
um when we can't see the data or we
can't see any transparency from
government
that is the suspicion that the industry
has is that it is politically motivated
at the moment going nowhere a leading
cancer charity says many patients are
still
shielding they fear the risk of new
coronavirus variants
thinning on top the warning from
scientists that the arctic
is melting up to twice as fast as
previously thought
an apparent change of heart an
anti-government journalist is shown on
state tv in belarus
appearing to praise the country's leader
back on show a year after he was toppled
the statue of disgraced slave trader
edward colston
goes on display in a museum in bristol
and east anglia and the southeast not
having the best day of weather today
heavy rain traveling its way up from the
near continent but elsewhere it's not
looking too bad
all the weather details coming up
shortly
good morning holidaymakers travel agents
and airlines have criticized the
decision
to introduce quarantine restrictions on
anyone returning from portugal
it's being removed from the uk's green
and travel list early on tuesday morning
following concerns about a new mutation
of the so-called indian
variant travelers are now rushing to
rearrange flights home
to avoid having to quarantine on their
return
let's look at what's changed no new
countries have been added to the green
list
people returning from places like
australia and new zealand or gibraltar
israel or iceland don't need to
quarantine
they're only required to take one
post-arrival covered test
but several don't even admit british
travellers
portugal has been moved down to the
amber list where it joins other popular
holiday destinations like
spain france italy and greece the
current
government advice is not to visit and
anyone who does must take two
post-arrival tests
and self-isolate at home for 10 days
countries added to the red list include
afghanistan bahrain costa rica
egypt sudan and sri lanka
travellers from those countries will
have to quarantine in a designated hotel
on their return at their own cost
aisha zahid reports when tim taylor left
for portugal on monday morning
his holiday destination was on the
government's green list
but three days on uncertainty
after portugal was pushed to the amber
list following a government review of
the traffic light system
it was quite frustrating uh it was kind
of
quite out of the blue you know we
weren't really expecting uh
portugal to to go onto the amber list
uh you know as far as we were aware the
cases here were
uh fairly stable uh and and
i believe lower uh comparatively to the
uk
tim is among thousands of britons now
plotting an
early return booking flights to avoid
quarantine rules which come into effect
at 4am
on tuesday morning i think when i first
looked
i think they were 99 pounds and i think
when we'd look back in the uk they were
cheaper than that and that's obviously
just for a single flight
in the time that i initially looked on
the page to go in through to the booking
processing
it got up to 145 pounds and that was in
the space of sort of five 10 minutes so
god knows what it is now
the government says the measures are
being implemented because of concern
over new variants but the decision is
another setback for the travel industry
british airways called it incredibly
disappointing and confusing
with bosses at heathrow saying it sends
a message that the uk will remain
isolated from the rest of the world
confusion also about a lack of clarity
from the government these decisions are
very politically driven
um when we can't see the data or we
can't see any transparency from
government
that is the suspicion that the industry
has is that it is politically motivated
at the moment
but experts say rising cases of covid
variants abroad meant the government
had to act this is a rapidly
moving and it's a very fluid situation
when it comes to
when it actually comes to the the covid
variants
and we have to lock down the travel um
place these restrictions on
international travel
so that we can actually unlock here in
the uk
for many like tim it's a long-awaited
foreign getaway frustratingly cut short
for others it's a measure to protect the
uk
and ensure lockdown restrictions can be
eased next month
aisha zahid sky news
meanwhile the cabinet office minister
michael gove is being tested
for coronavirus just days after
returning from the champions league
final in portugal mr gove had to abandon
a meeting with the prime minister boris
johnson and the leaders
of the devolved nations after he was
notified he'd come into contact with
someone
who tested positive
well let's speak now to the housing
secretary robert uh
generic good morning to you um first of
all let's talk about the situation with
portugal can you explain exactly why it
has been uh downgraded to the
amber list what is what is the reasoning
for that
well good morning i appreciate this is
very uh disappointing
and frustrating for some people but we
always said from the beginning that we
would do everything we can to protect
the uk from infection from new variants
and if circumstances changed in
countries that are on the green list
then we would review it and take action
accordingly
two things have occurred in portugal
firstly
the amount of positivity has increased
significantly it's doubled
in the last three weeks to a level
that's much higher than we have here in
the uk
and then secondly and perhaps more
importantly although
both countries have uh prevalence of the
indian variant or delta variant as it's
called
we're also seeing in portugal now
growing evidence of a further mutation
being called the nepal variant we don't
yet know how much of a problem that is
how transmissible it is whether it might
be be too difficult even for our
vaccines but it's important that we take
a cautious
approach and so we take action now
whilst we do research and learn more
about that variant
you did promise and that excuse me there
would be an end to the chaos of
of last summer where we saw people being
caught out we have
uh this instance as we we've just
described with michael gove
having to test he was pinged because he
visited
portugal i mean the chaos is back isn't
it
well the system that we set up uh has
three weekly reviews we've just
conducted that review
and we've concluded that one of the
countries on the green is portugal
admittedly a country that many brits are
on holiday in and want to go on holiday
in
but one country comes off the green list
and goes on to
the amber list people who are out in
portugal and want to return
before these new measures come into play
do have until tuesday
to do that so those people who are
planning to come home today or
over the course of the weekend will be
able to do so as normal
others of course might choose to to cut
their holidays short but it's right to
take a cautious approach
because we want to protect this country
we want to ensure that if we can we
continue to move
through the road map and do everything
we can right now
as we're approaching an important
decision about whether the 21st of june
reopening can go ahead but we again see
people scrambling to get home
they might say that the information
before they traveled wasn't clear can
you understand
the anger and frustration from those who
are now in portugal
facing having to change flights and get
home quickly
i completely understand how frustrating
this is both for people in portugal
and for millions of people here who
would love to go on holiday
abroad this summer but we were very
clear from the outset
that you should not be going on holiday
to countries on either the amber or the
red list
and if you do choose to go on holidays
it wasn't on the andrews
that's the point though isn't it it was
on the green list
yes but we were also clear that if you
choose to go on holiday
to countries on the green list those
countries are being reviewed
every three weeks and so there is always
a risk with a fast-moving situation
with new variants but countries might
either go on to that list
or indeed come off and that's what's
happened here and i hope that people
will understand
hard though this is that we do need to
take a cautious approach because
people have made such progress in recent
weeks and months
our own domestic vaccine rollout is
world leading
we've reached the point now where 50
percent of adults have had both of their
jabs
more than 75 percent of adults have had
at least one jab i got my first one
last week we don't want to risk all of
that progress
we now need to take a cautious approach
particularly
as we approach the decision as to
whether to reopen on the 21st of june if
you don't want to risk that progress
wouldn't it be simpler
and more straightforward to have a red
list
and a green list the confusion comes
when people are advised not to travel
within that amber category
well i hope that's not the case but let
me be clear
nobody should be going on holiday to any
country that is on either the amber list
or the red list the only reasons to be
going
for travel to countries on the ambulance
are the most exceptional ones
it's for example if you need to travel
abroad for medical treatment
which is rare if you choose to go and
visit say
a very sick relative or to go to a
funeral
overseas but again a very high bar
should apply
and then those individuals it still is
open for interpretation though isn't it
the the amber restriction is open for
interpretation
and labor for instance are calling for
it to be dispensed with completely and
be much simpler
to have a red list and a green list
i don't agree with the the labour
position which that they've just come
out with
we put all countries in the world onto
the amber list
and then if there is a reason to be very
concerned there's a problem
in those countries they go on to the red
list if we have confidence
that the data is good in those countries
and they have the genomic sequencing to
give us comfort
that there aren't new variants or we'll
be able to track new variants they can
go onto the green
list that seems like a sensible position
i hope people will appreciate that you
shouldn't be visiting
those countries on the amber list for
holidays you wouldn't
drive through an amber light at the
traffic lights you shouldn't be going on
holiday to those countries
either um you have renege though
on a promise to the the travel industry
to have a green watch list
whereby giving them a period of a week
or two weeks warning them
that this might occur you didn't hold up
to that promise did you
well we said that we do that if we can
but this is a fast-moving
situation so to look at the position in
portugal
not only has positivity doubled in three
weeks
that's pretty fast also they've got
evidence of this new variant
and i think it is really important that
we exercise caution when we see new
variants
when we don't yet know how transmissible
they are how virulent they will be
and most importantly of all whether our
vaccines will be effective against them
and so
we've taken a precautionary step that
gives our scientists time now
to do the research into that variant
let's hope that we discover that like
some of the other variants we've had
in the past that our current set of
vaccines
is sufficiently uh effective to meet
that challenge
but we all breathed a huge sigh of
relief when we saw that the
present vaccines were effective on the
indian variant
imagine how worried we would be if we
learned that this was the variant
which was able to defeat our current
vaccines there's no reason to believe
that right now
but let's be cautious do the research
before making a judgment
if you're so concerned about the rapid
spread of any uh variants or mutations
why have people been then been given
a four day window to to return home why
not
bring in the the measure straight away
well we think it is sensible to give
people a short window on which to return
precisely to the reasons that you were
discussing earlier because there are
british holiday makers travelers out
there
and we want them to return as smoothly
as possible to the uk so that we don't
see the sorts of scenes at airports that
none of us want
to see in the next couple of days if we
can possibly avoid it
just uh very quickly what was it right
that the champions league final go ahead
in portugal and so many
fans travel to the country we know some
of them have tested
positive on their return
well that was a decision for others but
we've got put in place robust procedures
if anybody
uh does come in contact with the virus
of course they should be self-isolating
and
going through the testing regime as
you've just said out that uh michael
gove will be doing
himself as well okay robert genwick
thank you very much for speaking to us
this morning
hello our reporter xavier chowdhury is
at manchester airport uh
for us this morning uh what's the
situation where
you are um we know that actually we were
here last summer weren't we in this
exact same situation
yes we've seen much of this before but
there is a bit of a difference this time
around some of the passengers that we've
spoken to today
who are traveling out to portugal they
seem quite resigned to the fact that
they're going to now have to come back
and self-isolate i mean the the big
thing is they're saying that they
they think that they weren't told in
advance that they booked travel to
portugal
specifically because it was a green list
country and that they're disappointed
that
it's been moved at such a short notice
to an amber but
many of them the ones that we've spoken
to today seemed very resigned that you
know
this is something that they had
anticipated that might happen
when they were booking their travels
sort of what the government has warned
that people would have known about this
but travel bosses and airlines are
saying that they haven't been given
enough notice they want to see the data
that the government uses
to make decisions like this they're
saying that there's not enough clarity
and transparency
at manchester airport for example they
say why have why has portugal been moved
to the amber list
when some countries should have been
moved to the green list because their
data suggests that they're
safe enough to travel to so they want to
see this data now
what the government is saying is that
the cases in portugal have more than
doubled since portugal was put onto the
green list
and that the variant of concern and this
is the thing we keep hearing about the
delta variant which we used to call the
indian variant
has a specific mutation in portugal
which could be more dangerous it could
prove to be more transmissible
and harder to beat using the vaccine and
that is the big concern
and public health england is currently
examining that
okay sadie thank you
now with many people's minds on summer
travel and what kovid means for their
holiday hope sky news has created a new
tracker showing the situation in
different countries
as well as finding out what's on the red
amber and green lists
you can search a destination to see
what's happening with a series of key
measures
like cases vaccines and deaths
you can see how the regional picture
varies and compare the country
to the rest of the world just go to
skynews.com
to come on the show we'll be joined by
the first minister of wales mark
drakeford at half past seven
as he prepares to ease lockdown
restrictions next week
there's concern a large number of cancer
patients are planning to shield
indefinitely the boss of the anthony
nolan charity
will be with us at quarter to eight
and at five past eight we'll talk to a
leading portuguese health official after
the decision by the british government
to remove the country from the green
list for international travel
one of the country's leading cancer
charities claims many patients are
planning to shield indefinitely
because of concern about the spread of
coronavirus anthony nolan says despite
the vaccine rollout many people believe
the risk from the virus
is still far too high fraser moored
reports
three years ago 18 year old sean wood
was diagnosed with aplastic anemia a
blood disorder usually treated with a
stem cell transplant
the diagnosis alone was difficult enough
for a 15 year old to come to terms with
but then came covered i was terrified
i had no idea what the pandemic would
mean because obviously it was also new
nobody really knew what was going on but
for somebody with a long-term health
condition that isn't going to go away
and it's such an immunodeficiency and
then knowing that you've got this really
scary virus that no one really
understands coming along you think to
yourself
oh my gosh my health's in such danger
sean has been shielding within a bubble
that includes her family
and her boyfriend jordans but her plans
to start university in september
are now on hold the blood disorder and
cancer charity anthony nolan
says their research estimates over a
hundred thousand patients are in a
similar position
with nearly half of those reporting they
would also continue shielding
after restrictions are lifted over a
quarter will continue to do so
even after receiving both vaccination
doses and almost three-quarters
say their mental health has been
affected we're in danger of a two-tier
society with blood cancer patients being
left behind
having to continue to shield
indefinitely
suffering with mental health problems
and not accessing the treatment and care
so they are a forgotten group of people
and it's really important and what we're
asking the government
to do is to think about providing mental
health support
for those patients as well as funding
research
into vaccine efficacy the department for
health says
our antivirals task force is working to
identify effective treatments for
patients
who've been exposed to the virus as a
way to stop the infection spreading
and accelerate recovery time including
individuals
who are immuno-compromised it goes on to
say while shielding advice was lifted on
the first of april
we've continued to recommend clinically
extremely vulnerable people
take extra precautions to protect
themselves
so for sean and thousands like her that
could mean
indefinite shielding and an increasingly
uncertain future
fraser moored sky news stoke
also making the news this morning a
belarusian
journalist removed from a ryanair flight
forced to land in mince last month has
appeared on state television
roman protosevich had been highly
critical of the regime of alexander
lukashenko before he was
arrested but last night he said he had
respected the president
for years
i started to realize that many things
lukashenko is criticized for are just
attempts to pressure him
and that in many moments he acted like
i'm sorry for this phrase but he acted
like a man with balls of steel
despite all the pressure and so on i
won't hide it
there were moments when i thought some
of his decisions were wrong
there are calls for second doses of the
pfizer vaccine to be given sooner to
combat new coronavirus variants
researchers from the francis crick
institute are warning only 32 per cent
of patients receiving the jab
had a strong antibody response in the
so-called indian
or delta variant
police in nottinghamshire say they're
searching for a five-year-old girl who's
gone missing
from the village of olatun she was last
seen just before midnight last night and
is described as white with
short blonde or brown shoulder-length
hair
black students have to work harder than
their peers to connect with
course content according to research out
today a study by the university of
leicester
recommends expanding the curriculum to
include subjects black asian and
minority ethnic students associate
with their own lives
british scientists are warning of more
extreme weather in this country due to
the loss of
sea ice in the arctic they're warning
that in some parts of the north pole ice
is thinning
twice as fast as previously thought
shingi morike reports
this is becoming an increasingly
familiar sight
as the earth's temperature rises arctic
sea ice is thinning
new research suggests the problem is
worse than we thought
some parts of the region could become
ice free in less than 20 years
scientists from university college
london have used satellite data to
calculate snow depth and density in the
region
the man tracking the numbers says the
findings are crucial
we found that sea ice thickness was both
more variable from year to year
and it's also declining in the coastal
areas of the arctic
much more quickly than we thought the
sea ice in the arctic is going to
continue to
thin this century and it's going to
continue to recede towards the center of
the arctic where it's really cold
and it's going to expose lots of these
areas they're going to become open water
in summer
and all the sunlight that comes from the
sky is just going to get absorbed and
it's going to contribute to a lot of
warming basically it's going to
it's going to get hot
although the arctic is thousands of
miles away
these changes are already being felt
here scientists from the ulu university
in finland found the thinning of sea ice
contributed to the beast from the east
which battered britain three years ago
one professor who looked at that link
believes more extreme weather could be
on the way
we have the gulf stream you know this
hot water current the warm current that
actually keeps britain
relatively warm and very wet most of the
time that goes up into the arctic into
the brent sea
and it sinks and disappears and that the
arctic because it is cold
absorbs that heat and should absorb that
heat now if it stops absorbing that heat
that's real trouble um that means that
all of our weather systems are going to
change
we have more extreme weather we have
like milder
but winters with but with more extreme
snowfall
one thing is for sure with global
warming continuing to change the world
as we know it
the problems on the horizon will be felt
far beyond the arctic
shingi marurike sky news
and for more news like that and stories
from the people trying to stop climate
change you can watch the daily climate
show on sky news you can join anna jones
every day
at 6 30 and 9 30 p.m
or if you're on the go you can download
and listen to the latest edition of our
weekly climate cast podcast
available now wherever you get your
podcast from
time for a look at the weather now with
joe
[Music]
look forward to brighter skies the
weather
sponsored by qatar airways
hello there well it's not a bad start to
the day for much of the country but it's
not necessarily going to stay that way
we've got this heavy rain coming up from
the near continent crossing the channel
and it's likely to affect
areas really to the east of the isle of
wight some quite heavy rain to come out
of that for parts of east anglia
and the southeast so through the course
of the day then northern parts of
england wales the southwest having a
lovely day temperatures 18 to 21
so really rather pleasant we do see some
thicker cloud across western parts of
ireland and scotland
that might bring a few outbreaks of
showery rain and those continue through
much of the day
and of course it's going to be rather
cool underneath this cloud around 18 to
20.
once the rain sets in it's going to take
until tomorrow morning for it finally to
clear away
into the north sea
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
still to come on sky news breakfast as
wales prepares for the next major easing
of lockdown restrictions
will be joined by the first minister
mark drakeford in a few moments time
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back concern about new variants
of coronavirus were behind the decision
to remove portugal from the green list
according to the housing minister
travelers are now rushing to rearrange
flight home
to avoid having to quarantine on their
return a short time ago robert jamrich
told me the discovery of mutations mean
restrictions had to be introduced
at short notice two things have occurred
in portugal firstly the amount of
positivity
has increased significantly it's doubled
in the last three weeks
to a level that's much higher than we
have here in the uk
and then secondly and perhaps more
importantly although
both countries have uh prevalence of the
indian variant or delta variant as it's
called
we're also seeing in portugal now
growing evidence of a further mutation
being called the nepal variant we don't
yet know how much of a problem that is
how transmissible it is whether it might
be be too difficult even for our
vaccines but it's important that we take
a cautious
approach and so we take action now
whilst we do research and learn more
about that variant
let's speak to our political
correspondent now joe pike minister
there saying that
urgent action was needed in response to
the changing situation in portugal
yeah and he was trying to show he
understands the frustration of holiday
makers i think that
it isn't easy that it is irritating and
really focusing on the 21st
of june the government seems to be
arguing at the moment that they are
doing this so we can guarantee we can
move ahead
with uh step four in england's route out
of lockdown the problem of course is
that
uh flights to portugal only restarted
two and a half
weeks ago it's a pretty uh swift change
why if they're so worried about the road
map and stage four
did we open flights until why are
borders open why did the champions
league
final go ahead and we see over 12 12 000
manchester city and chelsea fans
including uh michael gove
ahead across that many of them are now
south island including
the cabinet office minister michael gove
and really for the travel industry this
is very frustrating
for travelers i think it means if you're
prepared to take the risk do so but
really if you want to
desperately take a holiday abroad you
need to go last minute or don't
go at all for the minister not going as
far as saying that the traffic light
system needs addressing in the hole the
amber
um formula does need to stay yeah labour
say
let's get rid of amber it's very
confusing because as boris johnson has
said
and he and mr generic said today if a
country's on the amber
or red list do not go on holiday there
therefore what is the difference between
amber and red and mr generic had this
strange quote
about a strange line about the ambulance
you wouldn't drive through an amber
light at the traffic lights
so you shouldn't be going on holiday to
those countries either of course you can
according to highway code and i've
checked julian go through an amber light
if you are already across the stop line
or if stopping would cause an accident
you are quite
right that is correct perhaps he doesn't
drive thank you very much joe
now it's a year since protesters brought
down a statue of the slave trader edward
coldston bristol
now the top of monument is going on
display in a local museum
alongside some of the placards carried
by protesters who brought it down
our west of england correspondent dan
whitehead reports
covered in paint scratched and on its
side
the statue of slave trader edward
colston is back on display
twelve months after being dumped into
bristol harbour
an exhibition about what happened that
day is opening to the public
we don't want people to feel is that
this displays anyway celebrating or
on commiserating coasting as an
individual but it is a
important part of the history of the
city to really get an understanding
about its role in transatlantic slave
trade
and how we can move beyond this point
placards from the black lives matter
protest surround the statue
which will be housed at the city's mshed
museum
until a permanent decision is made about
its future
less than two weeks after george floyd
was murdered some
four thousand miles away in minneapolis
the colston statue here in bristol
was toppled its removal sparked protest
and change and what happens long term to
it
is a vital decision for the city just as
last year local opinion
on what should happen is mixed it's an
opportunity for people to educate the
other people who come to visit it
to tell them what kind of guy he was he
built the school and all that okay but
but he also did lots of lots of bad
things
put back yeah why not you'd want to put
back yeah i would
i know that was terrible why is that
well because it's just been there do you
know what i mean
if that was ours and it is history and i
believe his history gone by because i
believe
things have moved on it's from a time
where things were completely different
and i think i think it's important that
it's it's
memorized for what it represents now
erected in 1895 there had long been
calls for the colston statue to be
removed
when it happened activist jen reed was
there
down here and colton had come down i
made my
my made my way there really quickly and
saw colston
on the floor uh spray-painted red
with a box of jamming juice on his chest
and an afro pick on his forehead
and it was just a very surreal but
a very joyous moment the crowds were
going
wild everybody was really elated a
public survey also opens today to decide
what will go
on the empty plinth and what will
ultimately happen
to the statue dan whitehead sky news
in bristol
lockdown restrictions in wales will be
eased significantly
from monday groups of up to 30 will be
allowed to gather
outdoors well first minister of wells
mark drakeford joins me now good morning
to you um give us a bit more detail
about exactly how you'll be
relaxing the rules come monday
well on monday we'll take another step
forward in easing restrictions in wales
uh as you said 30 people will be able to
meet in a garden or in a park or
on a beach together in organized
activities outdoors then we'll
set new limits so that up to 4 000
people will be able to attend
an event which is a standing event and
10 000 people would be able to attend an
event that was a seated event
so that's a sports event or an arts
event for example
and this is a significant easement
provided things remain as they are in
wales today
in another two weeks time then we'll
move on to further easements for meeting
indoors but as ever we are lifting
restrictions
in a phased step-by-step way
keeping a very careful watch on the
public health context
and household meetings that that will be
extended won't it
yes as from monday we'll move from two
households being able to
form an extended household to three
households being able to come together
for that purpose and i know that will
come as a considerable help
to grandparents in particular who in
some cases have had to choose between
you know one set of grandchildren and
another to be in that extended household
uh if things remain uh as we hope they
will in another two weeks time
then we'll be able to allow any six
people to meet indoors in that way
but that's riskier and we're going to
wait to have another two weeks of
vaccination
we managed to offer around
300 000 extra vaccines over that
two-week period
and we'll have a better idea of the
extent to which that new delta
variant may be having an impact on wales
what have you been able to ascertain
about uh the
variant so far in wales what are the
numbers
uh well in wales itself we have fewer
than 100 people
and those cases are being carefully
managed by our local health
public health teams we have one
significant cluster
in the north of wales but again it is
being successfully
managed by public health action
we're more concerned about the extent to
which that new variant is spreading
across the border in the northwest of
england in particular
because it's just inevitable that if
that if that variant is now in community
spread
uh in england then it will come across
the border into wales
so we're watching that very carefully
indeed
how is that likely to affect those that
might want to to holiday
in wales are you thinking about that now
no
uh we don't believe that that will be a
proportionate course of action at this k
at this time we're very keen to welcome
people uh
to wales what we're asking people who
are coming from hot spots is
is to take all the precautions that they
can
to keep themselves and other people safe
so if you're coming to holiday in wales
from a
place in england where there's
significant amounts of the new variant
that we're asking people to bring their
lateral flow tests with them
we can supply them here in wales if that
isn't possible
but they can take precautions that will
make sure that they themselves aren't
falling ill and
as a result they're keeping people
around them safe as well
so it's asking people who are visiting
us and we're very keen to welcome them
to wales
to act in that responsible and careful
way
how closely will you be following uh
england
will you be taking the lead from england
as you know looking towards that uh 21st
of june
deadline for unlocking completely
well we're all on the same journey
across the united kingdom where all of
us
doing our best to ease restrictions as
quickly as we can
we will do that in a way that is right
for wales
so while i would be interested of course
in the decisions made in england
they won't be the decisions that
determine what happened in wales
we will carry on making our decisions
in a way that we think offers people in
wales the best defense
against this virus
running out of time just on that what
was it the right decision
to take portugal off the green list of
countries to travel to
yes it was the right decision the
figures in portugal
uh put them into that amber category and
in order to make sure that the virus
isn't reimported
into the united kingdom and into wales
that was the right decision
and what was it taken soon enough i'm
thinking of the champions league
final that was allowed to go ahead in
porto where we know that
several people have tested positive for
coronavis on their return
uh michael gove being a questioning
point um
he's been pinged and has to self-isolate
well we would always take a more
precautionary approach here
in wales truthfully we would not have
put portugal onto the green list
three weeks ago and i think it's always
important to that our first
lens that we look at these things
through should be keeping people
in wales and in the united kingdom safe
not allowing reimportation of the virus
and that would be the course of action
that we would follow
from a welsh perspective mark drakeford
thank you for speaking to us this
morning
thank you
time now to take a quick look at the
spot with jackie
this sports bulletin is brought to you
by vitality
committed to getting 100 million people
20 more active by
2025
the other word that i always remember
you referring to in team talks was risk
you're doing one nothing with 15 minutes
ago
what's the point in setting your back
forward your regular midfield and two
strikers
what's the point there the risk is
shove people in the box because the
other team react to that you shove three
and four in the box get the ball in
there
it's that's the risk because you can
lose the breakaway
the counter-attack quite easily and we
watch games that way
you were offended by it felt to me like
you were offended by the club being
beaten by liverpool or city at any level
and it made you angry
and the build-up to those games
your face was most a little bit like it
is now was it a dislike of you was it
the rivalry what was it that made you
feel that way because it was just
different in the club it's my respect
there with to liverpool
when i was at manchester united i went
down to liverpool
straining for a week and i saw the
intensity of their training and
and the consistency they had
so when i came to united and they were
running all the titles i made that point
and it's like one is aberdeen there's
only two clubs you need to be
in scotland to win everything that's
reason celtic
at that time when i came to united
there's only one club to beat to win the
white a week
and that's liverpool so that was my
intention
that was up ever then to produce a team
we could beat them
not necessarily beat them every game but
when these were the weeks
and i knew that if you beat liverpool
you're on the right path i only
recognized this properly when i became
captain for that last four or five years
that he used to stand
outside the dressing room door and the
captain couldn't go out past you until
you were there
every single match you make sure you why
did
it's this influence over referees this
looking down the corridor it's the
looking at the away team what was the
reason you stood outside that door
so that everybody could see it was it
for your own team or is it for the
others down the court
for their own team okay but there was
one occasion
i don't know if you remember this but we
were doing three nothing to
tottenham autonom and i never said the
word in the dress room do you remember
that yeah i sat in the radio
committed to getting 100 million people
20 more active by 2025
[Music]
still to come on sky news breakfast a
warning that despite
vaccines thousands of cancer patients
are continuing to shield
the picture across the uk over the last
12 months has been one of polarization
so we have seen about 20 of people
drinking less we've seen about half of
the population drinking broadly the same
as they did pre-pandemic
but we have seen about 20 of people so
one in five people
who have increased their drinking over
the last year and even in the last four
months
and within that we've seen a number of
groups emerge so
um parents and parents of younger
children school-aged children that we've
seen
as a group that has emerged as you say
we have seen
some definite correlation between people
who've had their employment status
negatively affected whether that's
through redundancy risk of redundancy
or free furlough and i think at
drinkaware the group that we're possibly
most concerned about is those people
that were already drinking
at higher risk levels so people who are
already
exceeding the chief medical officers
low-risk drinking guidelines
and a significant proportion of them
have increased their consumption even
further
over the last 12 months so of course if
you were already drinking at higher risk
levels and so the chief medical officers
low-risk drinking guidelines are 14
units a week whether you're a man or a
woman
and that's a bit less than most people
would think so 14 units is six to seven
pints of average strength beer six or
seven medium glasses of wine
six to seven double shots of spirits so
it's probably a bit less than much of
your audience
might think and of course that's over um
the course of a week now
many people do drink above that i think
the important thing to do
if you are drinking above that is to try
and understand actually how much
you are drinking and we've got some
fantastic cool tools on drinkaware dot
co dot uk
that can help you keep track of your
drinking that can help you understand
where your drinking is against those
guidelines and against other people
and it's very easy for behaviors to to
increase or to sneak in so we've seen
people reporting
drinking on days that they otherwise
might not have over the last 12 months
i'm drinking earlier in the day i'm
drinking to cope as we as we term it
which is coping with many of the
pressures that have been brought on
over the last years if some of what i'm
saying here does sound familiar to you i
think the overriding message is
you're certainly not alone and there's
lots of people that are in this category
what i would encourage you to do is get
to the drinkaware website there's lots
of really good information on their own
tools
hello my name is nadja frantier
my name is ryan matthews i'm the marine
assistant
at rather a research station which is to
the west of the west antarctic peninsula
[Music]
so far i've been here for five months
and it is an absolutely wonderful
experience
[Music]
did you know symptoms of hay fever can
develop at any stage of life
not just in childhood the pollen reports
sponsored by phillips connected air
purifiers
for many parts of the country it's going
to be another mostly fine day but there
is some rain making its way
up from the channel into parts of the
southeast and later into east anglia
we could see some heavy downpours out of
this so rather grim in that southeastern
corner elsewhere
sunshine or sunny spells and just a few
showers for parts of northern ireland
and scotland in terms of the pollen
count much of england and wales looking
at a moderate count but it will be lower
in the wetter east
it's low over scotland and potentially
moderate over northern ireland
the pollen reports sponsored by philips
connected air purifiers
a leading cancer charity says despite
the vaccine program
many patients are planning on shielding
some of them
indefinitely it's warning the most
clinically vulnerable will suffer mental
health issues after being at home
for so long joining me now is henry
braun chief executive anti-nolan charity
the leading blood cancer and blood
disorders charity good
morning to you um first of all just tell
us how
blood cancer patients have been affected
in general by the the pandemic in terms
of their
treatment and how they've been forced to
to live their lives
so what the anthony owen report is
telling us and what patients
are telling us is that over half of them
half of blood cancer patients are
intending to shield
indefinitely this has had a severe
effect on their mental health and over
75 percent
have reported um cases of mental health
and well-being
issues they've also had their treatment
and care
postponed all cancelled so it's a really
worrying
time for them and their futures look
very uncertain
and as you said blood cancer patients
have
really severely compromised immune
systems
why are they deciding to shield
indefinitely is this on advice or is
this just
a position that they've arrived at
seeing all the variables
i i think it suppose um i think their
advice
is to proceed with abundant caution
but because they are so clinically
vulnerable blood cancer patients their
immune systems are severely compromised
they really don't want to get covered we
also know
from recent research that the vaccine
really doesn't protect them
so they're in a really difficult
position and are very forgotten as we're
beginning to come out of you know
covered restrictions are being lifted
but they're facing a future of having to
remain
uh shielding uh tell us a bit more about
why you found that the the vaccine or
maybe at least the first dose
of the vaccine doesn't protect them in
the same way that it does for other
people
so we found that really only 13
of blood cancer patients got any
efficacy or any protection at all
as opposed to other people other people
in the general population
which means that their protection is
really really low
so they're understandably fearful for
their health and for catching
covid which would have serious
consequences for them
and this is because of their severely
compromised immune system it means it
just doesn't work like it does
for the rest of us and is that 13 after
the the first dose of the vaccine or
after the the full course
so that's after the first dose of the
vaccine but we're also
pretty sure that after the second dose
is not going to give them the same
protection as it does for the general
population which is really worrying
means as we heard earlier from patients
like sean
that their future looks really uncertain
and that it feels that they are a very
forgotten group of people with uh mental
health
issues and well-being so how can they be
helped
so we're asking the government to do two
things
they must provide mental health support
directly to blood cancer patients
and anthony nolan is also asking the
government to
fund research into vaccine efficacy
for blood cancer patients to ensure that
they can come out like we are
of these as coveted restrictions are
eased
and also many will need help
in terms of um shielding because reading
through some of the case studies it's
not just the the person
affected but also the family the wider
family some partners having to
to give up employment so that they don't
put
their partner at risk by going out to
work
no absolutely you're absolutely right
we've heard from one patient jennifer
and mom of two and her partner has had
to give up work
for fear of bringing kobe back into the
house
and infecting his partner so you know
people's lives have been
severely affected by this and they are a
forgotten group of people and it's
really important that they feel able to
go back into society
so we do need that mental health support
and we do need that research into
vaccine efficacy
and i would urge government to tackle
those two issues
what particularly would you be looking
for in terms of help with uh mental
health i mean
what have people been saying to you in
your research in in your studies
i think it's quite it's simple it's
people having people to talk to
to signpost people find support
it's it's basically having somebody at
the end of the line that they can
talk to and anthony lolan does provide
patient services
to our or you know two blood cancer
patients
but i think this is more this is a
dedicated services service through the
nhs through their clinical teams that
can support them all the way through
this journey
okay henry braun chief executive of the
anthony nolan charity thank you for
speaking to us this morning
thank you very much let's take a look at
the weather for you now
look forward to brighter skies the
weather
sponsored by qatar airways
hello good morning to you well over the
next few days the weather is looking
pretty good
fair amount of sunshine and some warm
temperatures too
today not quite so good at least not for
everybody we've got this area of cloud
and rain working its way up from the
near continent
and it's going to give some very wet
weather for parts of the southeast and
also east anglia with the cloud
extending
to a wider area than that but certainly
for much of northern england wales the
southwest
beautiful conditions today temperatures
18 to 21 degrees celsius
more in the way of cloud across ireland
also western parts of scotland
and this may give some showery outbreaks
of rain down towards the
southeast some torrential downpours the
odd rumble of thunder as well and that
wet weather tracking its way slowly into
the north sea it'll be the early hours
of tomorrow morning before it eventually
gets away but tomorrow it's going to be
sunny and warm for most
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
still to come on sky news breakfast
the government says portugal was removed
from the green list for
international travel following the
discovery of new covid19 mutations
[Music]
[Applause]
hello or like we say in my language is
lay i am toniti the founder and the ceo
of renewables in africa this picture
changed my whole career
and my whole life our mission is simple
is to bring back power
to africa and our need is to turn the
dark continent that i saw in 2008
into a brighter and prosperous one by
2014
so
you